Well, today we talked about here's Dr. Fulwapuvers determined their results, a couple times
I've received a free, almost expired or expired product which is very kind of you this
happened on the order I received yesterday, the product is called aloevia entourage 2.
It is a liquid with a dropper.
How should I take this and what will it offer me?
So whatever if you do get a free product because it's because it's near expiration, it's not because it's bad.
All our nutrients are good for two to three years after expiration, we can't sell it.
It's close to expiration so we give them away.
Aloevia entourage is a CBD oil.
So CBD is very good for a lot of things.
It has decreased inflammation in the brain, thereby it helps decrease anxiety, it helps decrease pain.
It attaches to cannabinoid receptors.
All your cells have cannabinoid receptors and it works as stimulant detoxification and anti-inflammation.
So would CBD be good for everybody to take?
Sure, it's just expensive.
It's not something I recommend all the time.
It's something that's used in the fenbenazole protocol.
And it's something that we sell a lot out because a lot of people are in the CBD for the cure that it does a lot of misidvermation out there that it cures everything.
But CBD is beneficial and most there's really no downsides of CBD except the cost.
A lot of people use CBD a day before they go to bed, it can help calm living, helps them sleep better.